regulatory issues are very important in
FTTH i'm joined by tony short or tony
you'd moderated a session covering this
very subject in fact questioning whether
telcos are going to actually take over
what was the finding of that must have
been a heated debate yeah i mean i
suppose one of the things there was a
consensus in fact about the need to
change regulation but i think depending
down on whether it was stephen task from
the incumbent community or Erzebet
vettori from the entrant community to
view on how that needed to change how
regulation needed to change was
different but everybody agreed for sure
that there needed to be a significant
change to the legislative framework now
i know you're an advisor to that to the
council here at europe but what do you
think you know how do you think it's
going to go yeah well i mean i think
it's kind of interesting i think there's
a big difference emerging between urban
and rural areas and what we're seeing
more and more are kind of market driven
solutions and urban areas where you get
competing operators deploying networks
certainly not over building each other
but what we see in countries like
Portugal Spain and France is that two
tree four operators build out their own
networks and wants to hit a critical
mass to start to do commercial deals but
then once you start to look at rural
areas the economics become far more
challenging and there you know there's a
greater reliance or there will be I
believe a much greater reliance on
public financing and you see at a
European level the European Commission
is trying to put together some funding
to help member states and already we
have cohesion funds deployed traitor
multi-annual financial framework so
there is a recognition that the state
has a role to play and helping to push
fiber you know try to communities and
yeah ensuring that there is enough
digital divide in the future and it's
not having an effect as far as you can
see yeah I mean I think so I mean I
think we can see already big initiatives
in the Irish market in the Polish market
where the governments are setting out a
clear stole saying that they want to
ensure that there's very high speed
ultra-fast broadband available you know
try rural communities as well and wanted
you know listening some of the other
sessions you hear government
representatives talking about the need
to ensure that you know it's ubiquitous
and they see it as a social on a
societal issue under state is really
critically important I think also being
technology neutral it is an issue isn't
it yeah i mean when people go to
allocate these funding it's one of the
founding pillars all of the regulatory
framework this notion of technological
neutrality but even that I think is
starting to change a little in the sense
that in the past the Commission and
public policy makers have really said
nothing about what a technology choice
should be and in a way i agree but it's
important also to set minimum
characteristics so a minimum upload
speed minimum download speed some
quality of service parameters you know
to ensure that you know the network
quickly if it's public finance that it
should be future proof so if we invest
today we shouldn't have to reinvest in
five years and that's a great thing
about fiber to the home networks they're
they're viable for the next 10 20 30 40
years and those are the time arises that
public authorities should be spending
should be thinking yeah absolutely Tony
thank you very much thank you right
thanks so the regulatory debate is set
to go on and probably on